you should have a solo career you could
have your own primetime tv series
wyatt put them on there
to brainwash me if you're hip to it you
can get paid to like talk about a
product
i'm sure you've noticed certain products
showing up in music videos and you're
like
that's a little random nothing is a
coincidence in that sense
nothing kgq i'm jack antonoff and this
is the breakdown
[Music]
first up bohemian rhapsody don't you
think i sound like
no that's good can we try it again sure
yep
sure it's your money this makes me feel
like when i was in a band and everyone
would feel the need to be in the studio
at all times
no matter what this is one of the
hardest parts about being in band is
everyone feels like if they're not in
the studio they're going to miss out on
something
can we try it again sounds a lot better
we need to get experimental that's uh
actually makes me anxious
the feeling of being in the room and
everyone's there and i was like dude
let's do this and you're trying to hear
something but you need time to get it
out but then there's also that part
where
they're sort of all coming together and
it's really thrilling i love nothing
more now than
having that energy but also being able
to turn it off and say all right now i'm
gonna
go do it alone the positive and the
danger of having people around
are the same thing which is their
opinions
you could use it or you could let it
kill you try bouncing his left and right
for the r
[Music]
well he's talking about panning it and
technically i mean one of my biggest pet
peeves in life is music and recording
and songwriting all these things
in film but this is totally kosher
it's talking about panning to use the
term bounce to one side or the other
that is
very quintessential queen thing of like
hard panning entire stacks of harmonies
so like one's here one's here and
they're all sort of
swirling together the thing that it can
be misunderstood about painting it's not
left and right
because within left and right is volume
and reverb so it can also be
here it can also be here you could have
something
move left from right you could so if
something moves left from right
or right from left right it's moving
this way but if it's moving in volume
two then it's actually moving
this way so i think one thing that isn't
always understood about recordings is
that it's a circle
i could go on about this forever this
totally checks out that's my point i'll
tell you these kids in the box
uh student band doing some weird stuff
how about demos you've got something an
engineer producer are
entirely different professions with lots
of overlap so an engineer
someone who'd get the soundscape and a
producer or someone would have
the ideas and produce the record and the
songwriter would write the record and
there's plenty of overlap so production
to me
is something that has gotten very [ __ ]
up in in our time because
the way people get paid the idea of
songwriter producer
engineer even putting mixer in this
they've all sort of like jumped on top
of each other
all of a sudden people were like the
only way i can make money is if i'm the
songwriter too
so then you have producers asking for
songwriting on things that aren't
necessarily
write it's become more commonplace than
you could ever imagine to steal writing
credit
and to say hey i was there wouldn't have
happened without me which is total
[ __ ]
let's fast forward you've got a gift
you all have so tell me what makes queen
any different from all of the other
wannabe rock stars i meet in any
industry of art the last person
to be taken care of is the artist and it
comes from this indoctrinated notion of
well you're lucky to be here
everyone plays into that i hope things
are changing and they're different in
other countries
in other countries where there's more
government attachment to the arts and
that scene is a real career it is
different but if you think about being a
kid in america and you say
oh when i grow up i want to be a
musician your guidance counselor might
say
good luck now let's have a backup plan
look i admire your enthusiasm
if it goes well if it happens i've got a
promotional tour of japan in mind
we want more every band wants more the
field of art is much bigger
than we give it credit for and there's
lots of work within it but we've created
a system where
because you're so lucky to be there
quote unquote we make the artist buy
that
and then we make the artist okay
with almost feeling like an
embarrassment about
trying to make a living within it from
my perspective starting out as a toy
musician the songwriter
you have to be extremely successful to
even begin to fathom to
get your own place support a family
there's just everyone's got their hand
in before you and that comes from this
feeling of well you're the artist you're
lucky to be here you're living the dream
so the reason why i'm telling you this
is because as the music industry has
become to bloat again
there's all this money we're just right
back to the 50s
artists are the last person to see the
the piece of it
love and mercy
[Music]
she's somehow closer now sometimes you
want to
hear yourself outside of the room so
you're taking your phone off
recording vocals is a really weird thing
to do
when you sing you hear hear yourself
outside yourself inside so if you
close your ears and
totally different right it's really hard
to to find a way that you enjoy singing
because there's really no way to record
your vocals
if you're isolating them and hear the
music that is natural right
so if i was singing right now this
drummer and a bass player or whatever
there's no way to record that
so i could hear it exactly like that if
we wanted isolation
once we were talking about this idea of
having like a wall where like you put
your face in
and the music plays behind you so you
can hear it then you could sing out it
would still create a separation but if
you can feel the music in your body
that means it's creating sounds that are
going to get picked up by the mic
one more time
they're doing it brian they've been
doing it for the past three hours
okay let's try it again please one more
time take 32.
32 takes isn't that much i mean it seems
like obviously that had been
a boiling point okay let's cut please
okay so
try it um more staccato okay you guys
are the the rhythm now
um so it's like an engine underneath the
side dennis can you be quiet please
while we find the sound
okay let's try it that looks great i
love that moving shot where you sort of
see everything else going on in the room
it feels really like what it's like to
be in the studio when
someone's trying to figure something out
and someone's noodling around and
there's all these other things happening
but nothing else matters okay let's go
again please
let's dig into this field a little
harder okay a little stronger
let's really hit it now okay here we go
it also feels so connected to when you
record strings typically string players
are sort of
raised and taught in a certain feeling
or theory of music
that if it's classical can be a little
bit more uh
rigid i know that feeling of like being
with strings you're like you're like i
know it's wrong just like
do it like this like you do it slightly
out of tune or whatever
you know and that scratchiness he's
talking about you always want especially
your cellos to get scratchier scratchier
scratchy or more percussive so that that
scene really speaks to me i think that's
beautiful
next stop pitch perfect too
all right uh hold up just hold up for a
second wait hold up
man i sound awesome right now what are
you talking about when i work with
people
on the production side we've been
working for a long time we're really
like chipping away to things so
it's pretty rare that i've had a
conflict as like sort of like nah that's
not good look it is good like nah it's
not you know it's like
it's not really that because we're so on
looking at the same thing it's more
conflict of like how we're getting there
i think the conflict we're seeing in
pitch
perfect too here is more of like a
session conflict when you don't really
know people and someone comes in and
they're like i'm killing it you're like
it sucks
but one time i was in the studio with
the chicks and i i like went to do
something and they came back and
they did a prank on me where natalie was
singing they pitched her voice one
semitone down and she pretended she was
singing it live and they were also going
like this and she was
a full semitone off key it sounded
horrible and i was just like
and they were all like and i was like
and they were like and i was like it's a
bit and they were like it's a bit
that was the only time i was with people
actually know when i was about to be
like guys what the [ __ ]
[Music]
i'm not trying to be contrarian or like
alt in any way but i actually think
snoop singing
this version of winter wonderland is
totally hip honestly if i was producing
this i'd be like this is cool the only
thing i'd want to do is undigitize a
little bit like
if you mix snoop's vocal with like for
example
some of the sounds we were seeing in
love and mercy almost like nancy sinatra
style recorded
i think it would be just a christmas
classic but every once in a while the
cover will happen where you're like [ __ ]
that might be better than the original
then you start to get into the concept
of production like wow someone could
write a song
it could be brilliant and someone else
could figure out a better arrangement
and that's crazy any ideas because i um
hear me out please dax please remove
the sleigh bells and put in
kalimba you know the finger thing
i know what a columba does go go in the
corner
go eat your lunch in the corner columba
wasn't a bad idea
the columbia was not a bad idea keegan
like okay who's playing the producer
it seems weird to me that i don't know i
guess that's the character like a
producer doesn't do anything and there's
people around
that he yells at and they give ideas but
if that was the case if he was that kind
of producer i don't imagine he'd even be
at the board
the way i sounded my eardrums this is
immaculate man
this song there's nothing nothing
special about it yet do you know what i
mean
in my experience things don't go very
far if they don't feel special because
then it sort of feels like what do you
what are you what are you doing if you
don't feel
this spark with something then moving
forward is a bit depressing and feels
like
a weird uphill battle please dax please
to remove
the sleigh bells light bulbs are nice i
like to use sleigh bells and sort of
drown them in reverb and then they turn
into this sort of like
jesus and mary cheney sort of like loopy
shimmery thing
sleigh bells are a kind of instrument
that would fall into a category for me
at this point in my life that
i don't like to use and have them sound
the way they sound
next stop straight out of compton
[Music]
the thing i really love about that scene
is when they cut to the booth and the
way they filter the music so it actually
sounds like headphone bleed
that actually sounded to me like i've
left the control room and i'm in the
booth when you're watching
a movie or a tv show and it feels like
surreal or music video it's usually
because of choices where like you're
moving throughout spaces but the quality
of the music isn't changing
alright so look your rhymes ain't tight
it ain't making a record
this ain't lonzo [ __ ] it's the real deal
all right so your [ __ ] better be dope
who up ran up that's not me to work
under that kind of pressure but it is a
lot of other people
and it's magical when you see it when
someone's like we have one day in here
let's go
you know i've had that feeling but then
i always sort of go home and be like
i wish that's not right and um i'm more
designed to be able to
live in something and sort of record it
when it hits me
next up is judging the pussycats white
gave me this cd of our song and it was
like as soon as i
heard it i don't know what it sucked
i love this movie the music was written
by anna from that dog did a lot of the
music for this movie that dog is one of
the great great great bands of the last
couple decades but she wrote some great
songs for this movie
you should have a solo career you could
have your own primetime tv series
wyatt put them on there
to brainwash me if you're hip to it you
can get paid to like talk about a
product
i'm sure you've noticed certain products
showing up in music videos and you're
like that's
a little random nothing is a coincidence
in that sense
nothing buy their cd you have to see
them in concert
you also have to buy steve madden shoes
you're nobody without an abercrombie and
fitch vintage t
they're selling stuff through our music
i think you'd be really clear about your
relationship
with your audience right so it's like
what are we doing here right
is it live shows and albums or is it
live shows
albums and anyone who'll pay me enough
money to sell you other [ __ ]
as an artist if the artist looks away
and wants all the i want a different
audience i want this i want more money
the actual people who give a [ __ ] about
you you'll never get them back you're
also trying to sell me things so
got it that's a a line that you can't
cross
back from when an artist you like starts
to chase something it's a very very
sad feeling alright that's it thank you
for watching these clips with me until
next time